whether it's taking the subway
shopping for groceries
or going into the office to do pretty
much anything in beijing these days
you're required to show this a negative
covet 19 test result within the past 72
hours
so thousands of pcr testing booths have
popped up in beijing and other major
cities across the country
the goal
to test people regularly in order to
spot the virus quickly before it spreads
plus beijing is back on high alert as
case numbers jumped in mid-june despite
the roll out of thousands of swabbing
booths beijing has been building and
staffing many of these testing sites and
that raises concerns about whether the
strategy is financially sustainable and
effective at stamping out the virus
here's a testing booth i walked around
in this area for about five minutes and
already found about five testing booths
and on this chinese map app you can also
find testing locations
in the three kilometers distance um you
can see that there are one two three
four five six seven eight pcr test
centers around me
i just took a free pcr test as required
by the bayesian government but making
sure that everyone gets tested
frequently and for free comes with a
cost
the city government hasn't revealed how
much money has gone into testing its
population of more than 21 million
people but based on the price set by the
central government of about a dollar
twenty per test it would cost more than
25 million dollars a day to cover all of
the residents in the capital
[Music]
authorities have started rolling out
regular testing sites in cities with
high risks
but economists estimate that if the
whole country were to adopt beijing's
72-hour testing requirement it would
cost up to 1.7 percent of the gdp for
comparison china's entire health care
budget in 2020 was about 7 of the gdp
and building a city-wide network of
testing sites also requires investments
in staffing and construction many of the
booths that i saw in beijing had at
least two people working in it and
according to chinese state media there
are more than 9 000 booths like this
here in the capital
some private companies that operate some
locations are offering a monthly salary
of more than 1 500
these stations also vary in quality some
are made up of a few folding chairs and
tables under a canopy while others are
more solid structures outfitted with
plastic barriers gloves and air
conditioners
all these booths tell us that china is
sticking to its zero covet policy which
is an approach that's becoming rare
elsewhere in the world
some analysts say china's strategy of
frequent testing may be able to reduce
some economic costs by preventing
city-wide lockdowns but this approach
can also become a financial burden for
the government in the long run china's
top health authority said it's necessary
to provide fast and high quality pcr
testing services in order to prevent the
virus from spreading widely still it
also said that not every city needs to
do that many tests
there are also questions about the
effectiveness of requiring regular
testing especially if some security
guards at entrances of public places
don't check the results closely or some
people just avoid getting tested at all
china's approach means that such
frequent testing and partial lockdowns
are going to be a part of people's lives
for the foreseeable future and that's a
burden on the people especially as they
start to realize that the rest of the
world has moved on from such strict
restrictions